Hola buenos días estos jóvenes están
preparando para una intensa jornada de
trabajo Se dirigen a un barrio hispano A
las afueras de Atlanta para promover el
voto de esta comunidad en las próximas
elecciones de medio término a que solo
una hora de Atlanta después encontrar a
comunidades marginalizadas que nunca han
nunca se han involucrado con el voto o
han empujado a sus oficiales a hacer un
cambio
están haciendo campaña puerta a Puerta
durante todo el día no tienen afiliación
política el objetivo es educar a la
población que muchas veces ni habla
inglés sobre cómo votar y cómo funciona
el proceso electoral en Estados Unidos
los invitamos a que se informen a que
chequen las propuestas de los candidatos
en base a eso ellos toman una mejor
decisión que les beneficie como latinos
350.000 podrían acabar decidiendo la
mayoría del senado como pasó hace dos
años en los comicios de 2020 por 11.000
votos de diferencia los demócratas
acabaron liderando la cámara alta el
escenario se podría repetir porque no
está claro el color político de esta
región todos los ojos están en Georgia
porque aquí se va a decidir de un
senador y sabemos que estamos a 50 50
entonces republicano y demócrata
entonces todo el mundo quiere ver quién
va a ganar porque eso puede decidir el
desde esta asociación que durante varias
décadas se ha volcado en las elecciones
y los latinos están viendo como ambas
campañas se han focalizado más que nunca
en la comunidad hispana y también que
los candidatos no es suficiente mandar
algo en el correo es yendo a dónde están
ellos para decir Este es mi cara me ves
en la televisión pero yo soy persona yo
estoy aquí para escuchar sí como apuntan
los pronósticos los resultados son tan
ajustados se confirmará que los latinos
también deciden el rumbo de Estados
Unidos seguirán siendo una minoría por
ahora pero con mucha más fuerza